have just had a joint statement from the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak and the
European commission president Ursula
vanderlein it reads this today president
of the European commission Ursula
vandelion and prime minister of the
United Kingdom roshi sunak agreed to
continue their work in person towards
shared practical solutions for the range
of complex challenges around the
protocol on Ireland and Northern Ireland
president Wonderland will therefore meet
with the prime minister in the UK
tomorrow let's bring in our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates so Sam
Wonderland expected in the UK tomorrow
that's right so this in this statement
interesting from two different
perspectives first of all it looks like
we are on the cusp you don't get Ursula
Wonderland in the presence of the
European commission she's effectively
ahead of the EU side of the negotiations
in to meet Rishi sunak until you're
basically almost there she of course was
meant to be coming over on Saturday to
amongst other things meet the king as
well as Rishi sunak that didn't happen
now it looks like she'll be able to talk
to Rishi sunak tomorrow could this be
the moment the deal is signed civil
sealed and delivered very very possibly
these two individuals will want to have
as it were a handshake moment when the
deal is finally concluded and that could
well be the purpose of that but
but what this statement does not say is
that a deal has been done what this
statement does not say is that there is
something going to cabinet right now
that's ready for Parliament to start
looking at and agreeing to you tomorrow
it doesn't say we're there and that is
interesting as well it's fair to say I
think that all day we've had quite a lot
of back and forth I've been speaking to
sources uh suggesting it's more likely
this evening and then more likely
tomorrow and there's been a little bit
of of flux in the air it has however
looked like actually you could get
something a bit more concrete than this
which is after all a holding statement
of sorts now it might well be that
they're just not ready this evening to
put it to everybody it might be that for
instance you had big brexiteers like
Steve Baker who's a member of the
government go in to see number 10 and
possibly put the brakes on things a
little bit that Richardson just wants a
bit more time either to look at the
presentation or the detail before he's
willing to press go on this deal the the
outline of which by the way has been
sitting on his desk for the better part
of two and a half weeks I mean they may
say there are still negotiations going
on if they are it's a comma here and a
uh at a dotted eye there uh it's not the
substance of a deal which I think was
sorted three weeks ago and even now
tonight they're not quite able uh to say
yes we're ready to go we're calling the
cabinet we're calling MPS this is
actually about to happen it's on the run
when it's going to happen tomorrow so so
another development but it's not quite
it yet and that in itself is interesting
okay I just want to jump in this time
because Ursula Wonderland has tweeted in
the last couple of minutes
there you go this is what she said prime
minister Rishi sunak and I agreed to
continue working in person towards
shared practical Solutions under the
protocol on Ireland and Northern Ireland
I will therefore meet with the Prime
Minister tomorrow in the UK so Sam back
to you what will this revamped deal what
could it contain
well I think there are three big changes
that Richard sunax been able to
negotiate the first is to effectively
make it easier to transfer to transport
goods from Great Britain to Northern
Ireland without any of the kinds of
checks that you've got at the moment at
the moment if you want to get stuff into
Northern Ireland because of that lack of
hard border and obeying single Market
rules you have to fill in forms fill in
permits the recorders this deal will do
away with all of that the second big
thing that Richie sinach I think has
secured is the right to determine things
like certain taxes such as vat and
things like the levels of subsidy state
aid as it's known in Whitehall to
determine both of those things from
Westminster until now Brussels had a say
in that because they wanted to make sure
that there was an unfair competition
when it came to uh when it came to the
Republic of Ireland the South and
um uh and make sure that there was an
undue competitiveness when it comes to
uh when it when it comes to the North
and the South and then the third thing
uh that Rishi sunak I think will be able
uh to say that he uh secured concessions
on uh really I think around uh just um
around uh the the kind of as I was
saying Level Playing Field and um uh and
tax rate and uh and I think between
those different things he will be able
to go to brexitis what he hasn't quite
been able to do is to work out how you
can stop that demand that brexiteers say
that they have a unionist have which is
to ensure uh that effectively EU laws
and new new laws don't come in and apply
to Northern Ireland so the third part of
the negotiation is the most complex as
it were there'll be something it might
be called a Stormont lock that gives uh
MPS the ability uh in all uh members of
the Stormont assembly the ability to uh
I think we're delay new EU regulations
when they uh when they come into number
10 when they come into Northern Ireland
but it won't be a veto and I think
that's the biggest problem here so yes a
big win on trading goods and removing
checks yes a big win on who controls tax
rates but when it comes to effectively
working out whether new EU Union laws
need to apply to Goods in Northern
Ireland and be applied to Goods in
Northern Ireland that's that's going to
be the really tricky and contentious bit
that's the thing that Mark Francois the
head of the brexit ERG was on the Telly
uh talking to Sophie Rich this morning
saying that's basically uh their Red
Line kind of making the situation better
isn't good enough for them what you
really need to do is to ensure that EU
law no longer applies new laws don't
have to be applied in Northern Ireland
that's their red line that won't be uh
granted there's no suggestion that that
Rishi zunak has won that fight which is
why perhaps explains why there's delay
and delay because at the point that
Richie soon actresses go on this deal
it's going to be an enormous fight and
if we're being honest we don't know how
big the fight is going to end up being
are there just going to be 15 Tory MPS
that go to the wall on this or is the
contagion led by Boris Johnson and Liz
truss brexite is fueled by the dep the
Democratic unionists are all of these
people gonna line up and condemn uh
Richie's unack's deal uh that is
potentially the case in which case he's
got a hell of a row on his hands and
there could be uh really quite a
backlash making it quite hard
potentially even for him to govern with
this uh with this route uh bleeding into
other areas of government so it's an
absolutely critical point on one level
no surprise that effectively they've not
come out with anything tonight but it
makes tomorrow look like a very very big
day
indeed Sam just talk to us about the ERG
we saw Steve Baker
tweeting a sign of the Westminster tube
and then we've actually got pictures I
think of him coming out with big thumbs
up so what role has he played has the
ERG played and what do you think going
forward they're going to be doing and
thinking about all of this
so I'm just looking at Steve Baker's
Twitter as we speak and yeah it's just a
picture of Westminster tube sign I mean
almost anything could be taken from that
does it mean I'm out of here does it
mean uh time to taxi for Baker uh or um
or or what Steve Baker is a vital
pivotal figure he's inside the
government he's a minister in the
Northern Ireland office many had
expected him to be the sort of guarantor
that this deal would work for the kind
of hard brexiteers that now are kicking
off but if he's unhappy potentially
might he resign we don't know I think
that Rishi CNAC will have to and have to
be seen to be listening to Steve Baker
very closely uh because of the role that
he plays now but also the role he's
played to put it bluntly uh
defenestrating past prime ministers not
least Theresa May so you listen you
ignore Steve Baker in apparel and his
Peril he's tweeting as if he might be on
his way we're gonna have to find out
soon